RECENTLY GIVING SAFETY IN THE
CITY A 10 OUT OF 10.
JOINING US NOW CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY LEO TERRELL, AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
WHAT SHE SAID FIVE MONTHS AGO
ABOUT SAFETY IN LOS ANGELES.
>> DO YOU FEEL SAFE WALKING IN
LOS ANGELES?
>> I FEEL SAFE, I WOULD SAY A
TEN.
I UNDERSTAND A LOT OF PEOPLE DO
NOT FEEL SAFE AND I RESPECT
THAT.
>> John: AND NOW WHAT SHE IS
SAYING.
>> ANGELINOS ALL AROUND THE CITY
ARE NOT FEELING SAFE, AND I DID
FEEL SAFE UNTIL MY SAFETY WAS
SHATTERED LIKE SO MANY
ANGELINOS.
>> John: WHEN I HEARD THAT, EASY
FOR POLITICIANS TO IMPOSE THEIR
VIEW PEOPLE, BUT IT'S QUITE
A DIFFERENT THING WHEN THEY WALK
A MILE IN THOSE FOLKS' SHOES,
LEO.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN, FOR HAVING
ME, HAS KAREN BASS' EYES BEEN
CLOSED AND EARS SHUT FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS?
SHE LIVES IN LOS ANGELES.
I MEAN, THERE IS CRIME EVERY DAY
IN LOS ANGELES.
AND IT'S FOR HER TO SAY NOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO YOU BECAUSE IT
AFFECTED ME.
AND I'LL TELL YOU THIS, JOHN,
THIS IS A CONGRESSWOMAN WHO
SUPPORTS DEFUNDING THE POLICE,
WHO SUPPORTS ANTIFA, BLACK LIVES
MATTER, SUPPORT GEORGE GASCON,
PROGRESSIVE, SOFT ON CRIME
CRIMINAL.
FOR HER TO SAY THAT NOW 60 DAYS
BEFORE THE MIDTERM I DON'T BUY
IT, I DON'T BELIEVE IT AND I
THINK IT'S AN INSULT TO THOSE
ANGELINOS WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS.
IF SHE DOESN'T KNOW, THERE WAS A
RIOT THREE YEARS AGO AND NOW
THERE'S JUST SMASH AND GRAB
EVERY DAY IN THE CITY.
>> John: YOU CALLED GEORGE
GASCON A SOFT ON CRIME CRIMINAL,
I THINK YOU MEANT TO SAY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN JUST A
SECOND, HER VIEW OF GEORGE
GASCON.
SHE IS PLEADING IN THE POLLS AND
IF THE POLLS HOLD TRUE COME
ELECTION DAY SHE MAY BE THE NEXT
MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES SO YOU HAVE
TO WONDER, HOW WILL THIS COME TO
JESUS MOMENT PLAY OUT SHOULD SHE
BECOME THE MAYOR.
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT SAFETY IN
THE CITY IF SHE BECOMES MAYOR.
LISTEN HERE.
>> NUMBER ONE JOB OF THE MAYOR
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ANGELINOS
ARE SAFE, AND PEOPLE DON'T FEEL
SAFE.
THEY WOULD LIKE AN INCREASED
PRESENCE OF POLICE OFFICERS.
>> SIMILAR MESSAGE TO THE ONE
THAT ERIC ADAMS GAVE WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR MAYOR OF NEW YORK,
AND WHEN HE WAS ELECTED, HE FELL
SHORT AND PLAYING CATCH-UP EVER
SINCE.
>> ERIC ADAMS IS WAY SHORT.
HE HAS -- HE DOES LOT OF TALKING
AND NO ACTION.
SO, HE'S A POOR EXAMPLE.
I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, JOHN,
HERE IS THE SAD NEWS.
KAREN BASS IS PROBABLY GOING TO
WIN THE CITY MAYOR'S RACE.
LOS ANGELES IS A SOCIALLY
PROGRESSIVE CITY.
SO, HER WORDS HAVE NO MEANING.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR, THERE IS NO
HISTORY.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANY HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SHE HAS NO HISTORY OF BEING
TOUGH ON CRIME.
YOU CAN'T FIND VIDEO OF THAT.
SO, THIS -- THESE ARE JUST
TALKING POINTS BECAUSE THE
ELECTION IS AROUND THE CORNER
AND AGAIN, ANGELINOS DON'T BUY
IT.
THE SAD PART ABOUT IT, I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES AND THE SAD NEWS IS
SHE'S GOING TO WIN.
>> John: NOW THE ISSUE OF GEORGE
GASCON, HE'S IN A RECALL FIGHT
AS PEOPLE TRY TO GET ENOUGH
SIGNATURES TO RECALL HIM AS THEY
DID CHESA BOUDIN IN SAN
FRANCISCO, DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT GEORGE
AND THE EFFORTS TO OUST HIM.
>> IF YOU RECALL SOMEBODY IT
SHOULD BE BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE
SOME AGREGIOUS ETHICS ISSUE OR
VIOLATED THE LAW.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
PRESSURE THEM TO CHANGE.
THERE IS AN ELECTION THAT WILL
HAPPEN IN A FEW YEARS AND HE IS
BEGINNING TO CHANGE SOMEWHAT.
>> John: HE IS BEGINNING TO
CHANGE SOMEWHAT.
SOUNDED LIKE I DON'T WANT TO SAY
SHE WAS GIVING HIM THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT BUT SAYING RECALL
IS NOT THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> SIMPLY SAY THIS, I'LL SAY IT.
SHE'S GIVING HIM THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT.
SHE IS A SUPPORTER OF GEORGE
GASCON.
KAREN BASS IS NOT GOING TO STOP
CRIME, SHE BELIEVES IN THE
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA, DEFUND THE
POLICE.
KAREN BASS IS NOT A FRIEND TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SHE IS A FRIEND
TO THOSE WHO WANT TO CHANGE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHERE
CRIMINALS CAN WALK 24 HOURS
AFTER THEY COMMIT A CRIME.
>> John: WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IN LOS ANGELES UNLESS SOMETHING
IS DONE TO GET A HANDLE ON
CRIME.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
TERROR, CONTINUATION OF CRIME.
I'M HONEST.
LIVE HERE, MY HEAD IS ON A
SWIVEL WHEN I WALK OUT IN THE
MORNING.
I HAVE TO LOOK LEFT AND RIGHT
BECAUSE OF CRIMINALS WALKING THE
STREET.
I MEAN, IT IS HORRIBLE HERE TO
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SUPPORT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IF ANYONE SAY ANYTHING
DIFFERENT, THEY ARE LYING TO THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE CITY.
IT WAS A GREAT CITY, AND FROM
THE CITY OF L.A. UP TO THE STATE
OF SACRAMENTO, THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SOFT ON
CRIME.
>> John: AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
EXPERIENCE IN LOS ANGELES WHEN
IT COMES TO CRIME AND YOUR HEAD
ON A SWIVEL, THAT'S REPEATED IN
CITIES AND TOW